die bevölkerung wächst und wächst und
bietet vielen von uns grund zur sorge
werden wir es schaffen 19 vielleicht
sogar elf milliarden menschen auf diesem
planeten zu ernähren wo soll dieses
stetige wachstum hinführen
die sorge um das wachstum der
weltbevölkerung ist total verständlich
was aber wenn es gar nicht über sondern
unter bevölkerung ist die für uns eine
bedrohung darstellt schaffen wir es
nicht nur mehr menschen zu versorgen
sondern auch weniger herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video auftakt oberson und
abonniert gerne diesen kanal um kein
neues video von mir zu verpassen
[Musik]
warface intuitives ist praktischen kurs
jetzt im moment sind wir ungefähr 7 7
milliarden menschen auf diesem planeten
in nur drei jahren sollen es schon 8
milliarden sein
für 2100 prognostizierte die un 11
milliarden menschen so lange ich mich
erinnern kann wächst die bevölkerung
aber warum ist das eigentlich so
nehmen wir einmal das beispiel
deutschland vor der industrialisierung
hatte eine durchschnittliche familie
extrem viele kinder
klar man brauchte sie als altersvorsorge
man wusste noch nichts von verhütung und
viele kinder starben auch schon bevor
sie erwachsen wurden also musste man
viele von ihnen in die welt setzen damit
zumindest ein paar von ihnen durchkamen
ab ende des 19 jahrhunderts wurden
hygienebedingungen und die medizinische
versorgung in deutschland dann aber
immer besser
heute hat ein säugling 40 mal bessere
chancen seinen ersten geburtstag zu
feiern als noch 1870 doch natürlich
hörten die menschen nicht sofort auf
kinder zu bekommen
das hat vor allem kulturelle gründe und
so wuchs und wuchs die bevölkerung
es dauerte mehrere jahrzehnte bis auch
die geburten in deutschland spürbar
zurückgingen kriege wohlstand und die
bildung von frauen waren dann weitere
wichtige faktoren weswegen immer weniger
kinder pro frau geboren wurden und sich
das bevölkerungswachstum in deutschland
verlangsamt und genau das die bildung
von frauen ist heute ganz entscheidend
für das weltweite wachstum
eine forschergruppe um den wiener
professor wolfgang lutz sagt voraus dass
schon 2070 schluss mit dem weltweiten
wachstum ist mehr als neun milliarden
menschen werden wir auf diesem planeten
nicht warum unterscheiden sich aber
seine zahlen so sehr von denen der
vereinten nationen er hat die bildung
von frauen stärker mit einberechnet dann
das gehirn sagt er sei das wichtigste
reproduktions organ der zugang zu
bildung ist weltweit ungleich verteilt
egal wo du dich auf der welt befindet
ist als man ist es wahrscheinlicher dass
du zur schule gehen darfst dabei ist
bildung nicht nur eine triebkraft für
soziale emanzipation sondern auch für
sexuelle das hier ist die bildungs rate
der frauen verschiedener länder in
zusammenhang mit den geburtenraten und
man sieht schnell dass sie miteinander
korrelieren
wenn frauen verstehen dass sie
entscheiden können wie viele kinder sie
bekommen dann bekommen sie häufig
weniger denn in vielen ländern die
welt werden schwangerschaften als etwas
angesehen das einfach passiert kinder
sind gottgegeben oder das gründen einer
familie ist eine gesellschaftliche
verpflichtung
es reicht aber schon eine einfache
aufklärung um dieses weltbild aufzulösen
und genau dieser prozess ist gerade
weltweit im gange in deutschland können
wir diesen effekt schon länger
beobachten hier liegt das jährliche
bevölkerungswachstum bereits unter einem
prozent die geburtenrate liegt sowieso
schon weit unter den 2,1 kindern pro
frau die es braucht um eine population
konstant zu halten aktuell wachsen wir
nur durch einen stetigen strom an
zuwanderern
aber selbst das reicht nicht aus es gibt
sogar schon die ersten jahre in denen
deutschland kleiner wurde ab 2025 zu
vermuten experten wird dieser trend
endgültig überhand nehmen
doch vor allem in afrika und asien wo
aktuell sehr viele menschen leben stehen
viele länder noch vor diesem
entscheidenden punkt die medizin und die
hygiene haben sich bereits stark
verbessert das heißt mehr kinder
überleben
doch die geburtenrate hat sich noch
nicht an die neue situation angepasst
familien bekommen weiterhin viele kinder
und die bevölkerung wächst stark an
und bevor ihr euch fragt ob wir all
diese menschen versorgen können hier die
kurze antwort im prinzip ja
denn kohlenhydrate zum beispiel
produzieren wir rein rechnerisch schon
jetzt genug wird zwölf milliarden
menschen das problem liegt an anderer
stelle
die lebensmittel sind falsch verteilt
außerdem werden die menschen bei
steigendem wohlstand nicht nur so viel
essen wollen dass sie satt werden
sie werden auch lebensmittel wie fleisch
und andere tierische produkte haben
wollen deren herstellung sehr
ressourcenintensiv ist der wunsch nach
lebensmitteln ist mit der aktuellen
landwirtschaft also nicht gedeckt daher
rechnen die vereinten nationen damit
dass wir doppelt so viel nahrung
produzieren müssen wenn wir die
nachfrage nach lebensmitteln auch in
zukunft decken wollen was doppelt so
viel
obwohl unsere landwirtschaft jetzt schon
zahlreiche ökosystem auf der ganzen welt
zerstört hat die menschheit wird
untergehen sage ich euch das dachte
zumindest 1789 der ökonom robert malthus
zu seinen lebzeiten näherte sich die
weltbevölkerung der eine milliarden
marke
die menschheit dachte bald sei es vorbei
mit ihr doch zieht ihn nicht zu grunde
fast zwei jahrhunderte später schrieb
der biologe paul ehrlich erneut der
kampf gegen den hunger sei endgültig
verloren mehr menschen könne die erde
nicht mehr ernähren tausende würden
qualvoll an hunger
berben die menschheit zu grunde gehen
doch überraschung wir sind immer noch da
denn es gab forscher wie zum beispiel
norman borlaug er wollte nicht aufgeben
und stand jahrzehntelang bei glühender
hitze auf einem acker in mexiko 1952
gelang ihm dann der durchbruch zu etwas
das so vielen menschen das leben retten
sollte dass er später den nobelpreis
erhielt er züchtete eine weizen sorte
die resistenter gegen krankheiten ist
und gleichzeitig mehr ertrag auf der
gleichen fläche land bringt es war der
startschuss für die grüne revolution
dank neuer dünger pflanzen und maschinen
konnten auf der gleichen fläche wie
zuvor weltweit sehr viel mehr
nahrungsmittel produziert werden
genug für alle menschen vor einer ganz
ähnlichen situation stehen wir jetzt
tatsächlich gibt es bereits zahlreiche
ideen wie wir mehr essen für alle
produzieren können
wir müssen sie nur rechtzeitig umsetzen
eine dieser ideen sind insekten die eine
wunderbare proteinquelle sein können
deswegen mache ich nächste woche
zusammen mit jakob von breaking lab das
selbstexperiment und werde einen burger
aus echten insekten essen
ich freue mich dann noch nicht drauf
aber ihr freut euch wahrscheinlich schon
drauf also abonniert gerne den kanal um
das nicht zu verpassen
nächste woche geht dieses video online
11 milliarden menschen zu ernähren ist
also nicht unmöglich aber dennoch wird
unsere erde wahrscheinlich stark unter
dieser masse bleiben also sollten wir
doch weniger werden
tatsächlich steht uns der große
wendepunkt kurz bevor
denn das interessante an den zahlen der
un ist nicht die bevölkerungszahl im
jahr 2100 es ist das was danach passiert
genauso wie wolfgang lutz prognostiziert
die un spätestens am ende dieses
jahrhunderts einen bevölkerungsrückgang
und danach werden wir nie wieder so
viele menschen sein wie zu diesem
zeitpunkt unsere probleme haben sich
damit aber nicht in luft aufgelöst sie
erwarten uns nun an einer ganz anderen
stelle weniger zu werden hört sich
nämlich erst mal gut an weniger menschen
wollten die natur weniger aus
produzieren weniger co2 und bekriegen
sich weniger um ressourcen doch unser
gesamtes gesellschaftssystemen also
unser steuersystem unsere
rentenversicherung sogar das wachstum
unserer wirtschaft sind darauf ausgelegt
dass viele menschen arbeiten gehen und
zwar mehr als in der ente
und genau das kommt durcheinander wenn
wir weniger wir hatten einmal kurz zum
auffrischen alle menschen die geld
verdienen müssen davon leider etwas
abgeben
sie zahlen steuern und sozialabgaben wie
zum beispiel die rentenversicherung
dabei bekommen sie das geld was sie dort
einzahlen nicht wieder
das wird nämlich an die menschen
ausgezahlt die zu diesem zeitpunkt im
ruhestand sind
wenn die arbeiter dann selbst einmal in
rente gehen dann bekommen sie jeden
monat geld von den menschen die dann
arbeiten werden
das nennt sich generationenvertrag doch
dieses system funktioniert nur solange
wie die arbeitenden menschen genug geld
einzahlen um das leben der rentner zu
finanzieren
denn die bevölkerung kann man sich wie
eine pyramide vorstellen
oben sind die alten jahrgänge die
menschen die zu einer zeit geboren
wurden als es jedes jahr noch viele
kinder gab
jedes jahr kommen jedoch immer weniger
kinder nach die pyramide dreht sich
quasi um das hier war übrigens die
generation der babyboomer und hier wurde
die pille eingeführt derzeit bezahlen
100 arbeiter 36 rentner 2060 könnten das
schon 51 rentner sein das heißt immer
weniger arbeiter müssen immer mehr
rentner finanzieren
okay was heißt das jetzt für uns wenn
wir nichts verändern dann kommen vor
allem in vier bereichen große
herausforderungen auf uns zu die erste
herausforderung sind die renten selbst
entweder bekommen rentner immer weniger
geld irgendwann zu wenig um davon leben
zu können oder aber die arbeiter müssen
bald viel mehr in die rentenkassen
einzahlen als sie jemals selbst
herausbekommen werden
eine schätzung hat ergeben dass menschen
aus dem jahrgang 2000 bereits 77.000
euro mehr in die rentenkassen einzahlen
werden
als sie später ausbezahlt bekommen
herausforderung nummer zwei betrifft die
wirtschaft vereinfacht gesagt wenn es
insgesamt weniger leute gibt die
arbeiten dann werden die firmen probleme
bekommen genug fachkräfte zu finden
das sehen wir heute schon viele firmen
können dann nicht mehr wachsen
ein ganz wichtiges element der
marktwirtschaft ist aber wachstum in
südkorea ist diese entwicklung besonders
krassen denn dort ist man uns zumindest
in dieser hinsicht sogar schon etwas
weiter voraus 2012 war südkorea noch das
land mit der drittjüngsten bevölkerung
unter den oecd-ländern oecd das ist eine
organisation der hauptsächlich
industrienationen angehören
2030 wird südkorea aber wahrscheinlich
das land mit der zweitältesten
bevölkerung sein
innerhalb weniger jahre könnten hier die
arbeitskräfte für die wirtschaft
komplett fehlen und auch die verteilung
der berufe ist ein problem in südkorea
lassen sich gerade noch zahlreiche
lehrer ausbilden
in wenigen jahrzehnten wird es jedoch
kaum noch kinder geben die sie
unterrichten könnten auf internationaler
ebene sehen manche südkorea als das
festland an an dem man sehen kann ob
sich eine industrienationen komplett
umstrukturieren kann
denn über kurz oder lang wird es sich
auch in deutschland frankreich
wahrscheinlich der kompletten eu und
amerika genauso entwickeln die dritte
herausforderung betrifft unsere
infrastruktur
sie muss umgebaut werden denn
wissenschaftler rechnen damit dass
weiterhin immer mehr menschen in die
städte ziehen werden
das heißt dort brauchen wir mehr
wohnungen während die dörfer verfallen
aber auch pflegeeinrichtungen und die
gesundheitsversorgung für eine alternde
bevölkerung sollten jetzt schon
mitgedacht werden
leider wird aber für all diese
zusätzlichen kosten weniger geld zur
verfügung stehen
denn wenn weniger menschen arbeiten
werden auch weniger steuern gezahlt
logisch dass geld fehlt dann auch zum
beispiel beim umweltschutz oder bei
bildungseinrichtungen die vierte
herausforderung betrifft unsere
demokratie selbst denn sie macht politik
für die mehrheit der bevölkerung was ja
an und für sich gut ist wird dann vor
allem und junge menschen stören denn
wenn es verhältnismäßig mehr alte
menschen gibt kommen natürlich auch er
parteien zum zug die politik für ältere
machen wie sich das auf das
selbstverständnis der heranwachsenden
generation auswirkt wenn sie das gefühl
haben von der demokratie nicht gehört zu
werden
das wird gerade noch untersucht jetzt
müssen wir aber nicht gleich den kopf in
den sand stecken oder die demokratie
abschaffen denn wir menschen wären ja
nicht menschen wenn wir nicht sehr
erfinderisch wären es gibt tatsächlich
bereits erste ideen wie wir uns dem
demografischen wandel stellen könnten
die erste ist natürlich doch wieder mehr
kinder zu bekommen doch das ist
tatsächlich leichter gesagt als getan
auf der ganzen welt wurden schon
verschiedenste programme ausprobiert um
die bevölkerung der industrienationen
zum kinderkriegen zu bekommen in
südkorea ist mittwoch zum beispiel
familientag um 18 uhr wird in den büros
eine durchsage gemacht und das licht
ausgeschaltet damit die menschen nach
hause gehen und sich um ihre familie
kümmern oder eine neue familie gründen
im singapur finanziert die stadt zum
beispiel salsa kurse für singles bei
denen sich menschen kennenlernen sollen
und es gibt eine national neid die paare
dazu animieren soll sex zu haben und
kinder zu
auch deutschland ist aktiv die
riester-rente das elterngeld oder der
rechtsanspruch auf einen betreuungsplatz
für kinder sind maßnahmen die gegen den
demografischen wandel bereits ergriffen
wurden bisher half nur leider nichts
auch eine zweite lösung wird schon offen
in der politik diskutiert sollten wir
das renteneintrittsalter hoch setzen
oder sollen die rentenbeiträge erhöht
werden
beides ist zugegebenermaßen nicht
besonders toll wir arbeiten ja ohnehin
schon fast unser ganzes leben lang und
zahlen auch jetzt schon sehr viele
steuern aber auf jeden fall wurde das
problem erkannt es gibt sehr viele
gremien und verbände die sich in
deutschland schon seit jahren mit diesem
thema auseinandersetzen und in
skandinavien gibt es sogar schon erste
vorbilder in schweden zum beispiel
steigt das rentenalter automatisch wenn
die lebenserwartung der menschen steigt
so gibt es keine proteste wie zum
beispiel die gelb westen in frankreich
wenn sich die gesetze schlagartig an die
realität anpassen
in dänemark ist das renteneintrittsalter
von vornherein flexibel
wer hier länger arbeitet wird hinterher
belohnt die dritte idee ist nicht neu
tatsächlich hat sie den demografischen
wandel bei uns in den letzten
jahrzehnten schon sehr effektiv
verlangsamt es ist die emigration
egal ob man jetzt pro oder contra zu
einwanderung steht gegen den
demografischen wandel hilft sie auf
jeden fall
manche experten sagen sogar dass in
zukunft weltweit ein wettstreit um
einwanderer beginnen wird
schon jetzt machen sich erste
unternehmen gedanken wie sie möglichst
attraktiv für internationale
arbeitnehmer sein könnten
das ist übrigens auch eine gute
nachricht für uns junge menschen je
weniger arbeitskräfte es gibt desto mehr
vorteile haben wir am arbeitsmarkt wer
seine arbeit gut macht wird gebraucht
und umworben
mit der vierten idee können wir direkt
heute anfangen es ist ein wandel in
unseren köpfen
was denkt ihr wenn ihr an 60-jährige
menschen denkt welches bild habt ihr vor
augen wenn ihr euch ein 70 jähriges paar
vorstellt seid ehrlich so was hier in
unserer gesellschaft gelten ältere
menschen häufig als verbraucht die tun
jetzt noch mehr was eigentlich kaffee
trinken und dann sind sie irgendwann weg
wer mit 50 seinen job verliert der wert
sätze wie mit deinem alter findest du
aber auch nichts mehr neues oder doch
das muss nicht so sein wenn man
durchschnittlich über 80 wird dann kann
man mit 50 locker auch noch eine neue
ausbildung anfangen
und wenn man möchte kann man mit 70 sehr
wohl noch arbeiten
in jedem fall sollten wir die zeit und
lebenserfahrung von älteren menschen in
die mitte der gesellschaft holen
ob nun tatsächlich als arbeiter oder im
wohlverdienten ruhestand mit den enkeln
oder in ehrenämtern alter hat nichts mit
ende zu tun
die möglichkeiten sind so vielfältig wie
unsere fantasie und tatsächlich ist an
dem demografischen wandel auch nicht
alles schlecht unser planet zum beispiel
freut sich sehr wenn weniger menschen
auf ihr leben
dennoch brauchen wir dringend ansätze
wie wir unsere gesellschaft neu
gestalten wollen